tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo video
sono fa vj e chiude come potete vedere
sono tornato nella mia regge
siccome sono a torino dai miei genitori
ragazzi in questi giorni non potevo
registrare niente e quindi siccome un
sacco di persone ancora non l'avevano
visto preso il gameplay di sixty seconds
che avevo fatto nella live circa
un'oretta durava e l'ho tagliato
facendosi un video visto che ancora non
era uscito il video in se l'ho tagliata
quindi ho messo soul i momenti migliori
della giocata sixty seconds della live
che ho fatto la settimana scorsa quindi
buona visione
ho veramente bisogno che voi mi date una
mano in questa merda perché non è
possibile che io 800 episodio fatto non
l'ho mai finito se non lo finisco
stavolta non lo so io io stavolta o non
voglio cazzi e io non voglio cazzi deve
finire mi sono rotto siamo riusciti a
chiudere la botola va beh questo è prima
dell'esplosione solita storia abbondante
scorta d'acqua dai raga miglia stavolta
li vedo più carichi del solito per come
sono belli contenti stavolta finiamo
nessuno mangia nessuno beve va attaccata
a un cazzo siamo avanti tanto i primi
giorni livelli contaminazione ok allora
la canon mando nessuno fuori nessuno non
avremmo mai immaginato di vivere così a
lungo da vedere uno scarafaggio danzare
cosa dei roditori mutanti stanno
assaltando le nostre problema ma laddove
mica entra sta gente
e vabbè se devo dire sparagli però
perché entra dado vento hanno sti
roditori mutanti spiegami c'è il bunker
è un bunker come fanno adesso la nostra
e lattine sono salve va bene i
sopravvissuti malconci ci hanno fatto
visita tutto ciò che volevano era
qualcosa da bere qualcosa da mordere o
perlomeno qualche benda pulita ma i
nostri ospiti sono scoppiati in lacrime
quando abbiamo dato loro due che avevano
chiesto po come me quando non mi friends
on
non voglio leggere starò a bocca ci
hanno dato una cazzo di radio no raga
potremo vincere dovrebbe mangiare cose
pensione condizioni acqua e cibo a tutti
i paesi meno meritate acqua e cibo
raga abbiamo una radio che abbiamo la
mappa è passato molto tempo non abbiamo
notizie la situazione accendiamo la
radio
vai con radio maria e via timi può
farcela dimmi credo in te fucile
no non aspetta sì dài fucile però non si
può sopportare i proiettili allora noi
niente fucile perché mi sembra la
valigetta giusto dalla fascia la voglio
intera quando ti ammazzo rovistando in
giro medicine ha trovato un asse un semi
di piante non sappiamo di cosa si tratti
ma abbiamo l'occasione di far nascere
qualcosa di grandioso con un pizzico di
fortuna avremo tra le mani un melo per
piantarlo dovremo usare una bottiglia
d'acqua che si fa secondo me mi esce
fuori chernobyl dal suo caso però va
bene usiamola sopra che non l'ho mai
fatto prima sono curioso di capire che
cosa succede ora gal acqua quasi finita
se jimmy non torna con una tanica di
acqua panna e tornato al bastardo avvio
l'acqua se non hai trovato l'acqua
t'ammazzo mancato poco
però così preoccupati parti mi è
riuscito a tornare ora al sicuro con noi
prima lascio ti adoro bambino dai
capelli alquanto schifosi più uno di
zuppa più 2 d'acqua
bambino utile papà ti do lascia voglio
fuori con la maschera a mano con la
maschera
magari poi incontra di tutto e lo
spaccano di botte non si può difendere
ma gli picchi con la maschera zio ted e
uscite spedizione speriamo che torni
presto con le più belle tutto
l'equipaggiamento ok annuncia
radiofonico nell'esercito perlustriamo
il quartiere alla ricerca di
sopravvissuti ma hanno bisogno di segni
evidenti della presenza di persone per
indicare quanti di noi occupino il
rifugio dobbiamo lasciare delle carte
alla più vicina fermata dell'autobus
perché la sopravvivenza di questi
stronzi dipende da un da un mazzo di
carte perché io devo mettere un mazzo di
carte dalla fermata dell'autobus per far
arrivare
l'esercito per salvarci belec e che cosa
cazzo te ne fai delle carte che cazzo
sei jack nobile scrivi su un foglio
siamo vivi siamo qui cosa te ne fai
delle carte più ti ammazzo la famiglia
buttatela stermino abbiamo perso
l'occasione di santa maria la nova
ma può ma butta tuo figlio morto e digli
sour i miei familiari sono lì io sto
morendo fotte sega con molta probabilità
torneranno ancora ma quando è quando
troverò le carte continuate le valigie
in uscita per ciò che le provviste
tornata una ferita sull'avambraccio
niente di serio diceva ma sembra che
qualcosa l'avesse morsa e quella ferita
sveglia è peggiorata molto teniamo si
sia infettate dobbiamo veri carla era
questo che cercava l'altra volta mary
jane che il tuo braccio pesa quanto
metti un po il braccio su questo che il
tavolo
por qué ma quanto sono contento luci
volta non sono riuscito a farlo adesso
lo faccio sorridi
chissà che cosa succede ma c'è ancora ma
come mary jane ha frainteso quando ci ha
visto con lascia in mano ha cercato di
zoppicare fuori dal bunker ma per
fortuna era troppo lente siamo riusciti
a spiegare le nostre intenzioni con la
lama della cia riscaldata abbiamo
disinfettato la ferita è fermato
l'infezione ma io volevo che l'età gli
assemblaggi c'è troppo buonismo in
questo gioco ma dagli ha visto braccio
dyer che avete anche più da mangiare le
carte le carte le carte no alla zuppa
non me ne frega un cazzo due di a se tu
sei stato fuori una settimana e hai
portato una zuppa e due di acqua che
vado al carrefour qua sotto le compro in
un minuto
sei stato quattro giorni fuori dove
cazzo sei andata a gardaland descartes e
servono me ne frega dell'acqua si
sopravvive con col poker si sopravvive
non ne avete non voi non sapete nulla di
sopravvivenza se seguite bear grylls
sapreste che servono le carte da poker
nelle carte raga le carte perché me
dovresti andare fuori con una radio
creazzo fi gangster
mary jane devi tornare con le carte e
dato d'uno imprendi cibo perché tu lo
mangi già milita quando vi andate andate
a fare i navi seals che mi fate
l'addestramento dicono le a destra non è
caso di apocalisse di radiazioni
nucleari
dovete chiamare le famiglie dire mettete
le carte fuori questo insegnano i
marines è i navi seals abbiamo ricevuto
il comunicato dall'esercito timori se la
famiglia malissimo chi morisse la
famiglia in overdose di zuppa è tornata
a quella cosa mai portato quanto mai
portato quelle napoletane no perché non
l'accettano quella è solo la poca cosa e
portato purtroppo le ricerche sono stati
inutili
non abbiamo ottenuto nulla da questa
escursione botte che sei stato fuori 45
giorni eto'o in 45 giorni
[Musica]
hai portato in piazza bere dell'acqua
con un brava show bere l'acqua non la
meritate deficienza solo lei se la
merita che deve uscire
voi non vi faccio per niente ziato la
dama la dama esci con una dama clicca
cosa fai
le scivola maschera
ragazzi io però non so 30 set
ma qualche ha vinto associato come cazzo
ha fatto devo ascoltare un po di musica
cazzo chamartin garics non avevamo cibo
per suonare anche mary jane quando l'ho
scoperto ci ha lanciato una terribile
occhiataccia ma se abbiamo 800 zuppe che
minchia la knorr ha chiuso la fabbrica e
ce l'abbiamo noi
ottocento zuppe mi offri la dama che
cielo la radio che ce l'ho il gip che
cielo le munizioni che tanto non mi
servono
ma le carte non me ne dai le carte ma
dove cazzo è mary jane dove la figlia
non l'ho visto cosa è successo è sparita
mia figlia in un bunker siamo meyer dove
si vede che io a furia di non leggere mi
salto le cose niente quando ci ha
lasciato l'occhiataccia che non
c'eravamo il cibo non è vero abbiamo 300
zuppe ed efficiente va bene se n'è
andata perché non le davamo del cibo va
bene se andavi alla mensa della mia
scuola media go karts che mangiava stavi
a digiuno
capitan siamo donna ti amo sei mani le
inutili ma fermi a due bottiglie d'acqua
ma fare un cazzo di quello che è
successo a farmi leggere queste successo
più due più due di di acqua quindi
abbiamo mica la tanica le carte io non
ci posso che guardare come siamo messi
accendete sta minchia di radio avete le
carte avete la radio e della mappa vedi
tutto tutto avete quello scemo diamine
regalerà una trappola esplosiva appena
l'abbiamo aperta esplosa a dio le carte
vale letto le carte le carte bene
abbiamo messo le carte per i militari
l'unica roba che dobbiamo fare è
sopravvivere
l'unica solo quella dobbiamo farla solo
le carte sono posizionate degli ac dc ce
ne scampi
ora possiamo solo aspettare che
l'esercito ci localizzi non dovrebbero
impiegarci morto in teoria haga dai
militari schifosi dio santo se vinco
vela oggi siamo al giorno 49 dio santo
56 o ma basta detto sta coltivando la
partita militari schifosi
raga siamo alla resa dei conti siamo
alla fine per forza adesso dove succede
qualcosa attorno è in crisi c'è un
quella è morta sono rimasto solo io
solo io sono rimasto basta che
sopravvivono hard band si è ferito
quando un condotto bloccato dio
militari vi prego vi prego un gruppo di
banditi alle porte ancora fucile ma non
ora e non ai proiettili
ti prego non morire non morire non
morire non morire non morire 62 non sono
morto
gli ho dato il fucile in testa si è
rotto come cos'è successo
stavolta siamo riusciti a battere i
bandi ma non avevi proiettili che hai
fatto perché non ci contattano stanno
entrando i banditi di nuova ridaje
pensavamo che questi banditi volessero
ucciderci invece hanno preso solo tempo
e l'hanno portato via
speriamo che non gli succeda niente di
grave il peccato è che ted era l'ultimo
quindi verso 65 giorni 60 65 giorni che
equivalgono a un'ora della mia vita
un'ora un'ora della mia vita buttata nel
cesso e quindi niente ragazzi non è
quello che hai le carte ai la mappa in
tutto il cazzo che ti serve non c'è
verso le vincerà questo gioco delle
palle quindi ragazzi niente io ci ho
provato in tutti i fottuti monito gioco
infattibile quei ragazzi sperare sia
piaciuto quello che mi piace anche se ci
mettiamo così un video bella ragazzi
[Musica]